foreign
[Music]
here is your opening triangles right
there you see my body goes right
position
your body goes on one side
your arms go in the other you have this
arm
fight it and then yield
and he'll land
and it's on
oh I need to yield it's on
oh
tan Khan out of those
[Music]
foreign
do you see how he's not coming at me you
see that
so if he comes at me you see this way
that's the order version cool
but this time it's not coming in okay
his energy he waited there so I'm gonna
come in
see and then I'm going to make this
shoulder go down
right into the braid
so don't try
to go this way and pull him
this one's going forward
boom right here
then shoulders down
attack the arm like this then shoulder
down
is located
try something different go
collaboration another variation
[Music]
I'm gonna keep everything where it is
and bring my knee in
this way okay and the dislocation I want
you to be sure you tap on let me
dislocate your arm okay I'm going to
step forward boom and I walk
you might not be able to do that
but you can head that way okay
come in
this way and I start to walk forward
and be going like this
okay crack
yarn down
down in
okay you could do it with just your
weight shifting here
into the elbow
not on this torso
put
this is a handless technique
okay
so I'm doing my part
and
then time
come around I'm not holding anything
here get out of the way we're doing your
hips
you see okay and then stay low
Drive
into his elbow and your hip
does
you see that okay
he might want to post up
push your hand and start turning this
low and try to roll out of it okay when
you see him post come underneath Boom
come over here and now you have both
[Music]
foreign
see how I have this wrist okay I'm gonna
let it pass
to my hip
it's in the way
let it go okay
he starts posting grab it this way if
you need two hands grab what you hands
pull it up
then attack the elbow
it's not a free-for-all whatever are you
okay
you have to work with his skeletal
system so when he's down
a normal katakatane
you're attacking the scapula mechanism
okay
it's not it's not in his elbow so this
arm
is going to press this scapula down
towards the ground this way okay
to do that with your legs you would have
to stand up like I tried to show but
it's just too tight so we're not going
to do it tonight do you understand so
when I'm here like this
this foot
imagine I'm here this foot steps up and
that's the same downward pressure you
see
you have uh it's not really cutting a
Tama anymore but if you go to your
nebuaza you have the Kimura
usually from here right and you're gonna
work it I can do a katakatama variation
here the same way you see how I'm moving
it I move the scapular mechanism or I
can attack the elbow
you see by rotating elbows goes back
towards me
wrist goes around the elbow you see that
that's what you have here
we changed it
as I bring this to his
elbow
the elbow's going towards me
do you see that it's going backwards
it's not going forward
okay
so I come this way I'm turning here
but I'm doing it with my body
so he posts up
and I go to get the arm
I don't want it down here pull your arm
out like
the takeaway is leverage it's up here
you see
and when you get his two arms like this
you control his hips uh try to bring
your knees under your hips
you see
he'd bring his hand up like this try to
do it
try to understand that okay the higher
the shoulder pin is the harder it is for
someone to get their hips under them so
here you uh do hip control do you see
and then you break his other arm
okay so this
is hip control this is the elbow
dislocation okay
try it again don't put your weight on
his
back
that that doesn't work so he puts his
weight on my back
was that knee on my back you see uh I
can I'm gonna move because he never
really has Arm Control
do you understand you're never going to
be heavy enough that I can't move you
that way okay so you're attacking the
elbow with the knee and then the other
one is hip control bring that up high
okay go slow but smooth get everything
in the right place go